the terror threat levels aren't getting
any lower but the intelligence agencies
appear to be catching up intercepts and
surveillance brought the authorities to
sand any and this huge operation to
round up the terror gang who killed so
many people in Paris at the top of the
pile was this man abdel hamid a borrowed
a belgian resident of moroccan descent
with a well publicized history of
jihadist involvement and thought to be
the mastermind behind the friday attacks
and others as well the french
authorities say he was not arrested but
that a man is dead he's something of a
poster boy for Islamic States foreign
fighters in this video he urges Muslims
to take up arms it's not known when it
was filmed but was posted on social
media as Islamic state propaganda
possibly before a militant attack in it
he goads Muslims to take up jihad asking
if they feel happy or if they feel
humiliated the concern for everyone is
that he was thought to be in Syria if
not he has travelled through much of
Europe undetected something he's boasted
about in the past whereabouts unknown is
another suspect Salah Abdeslam he is
seemingly slipped through the net
despite being stopped by the police he's
disappeared that alone is a great
concern to the authorities it's an
indication of the extreme difficulty of
actually tracking people who will have a
number of places safe safe places that
they can go to and they will move around
and we must assume that behind these
atrocities there's a network of people
and so their movement of people who are
on the run on this way it will be
facilitated by that Network intelligence
services may not be overwhelmed but
there's some close analysis taking place
about how to stop these crimes before
they happen what's happened here since
Friday is raising fundamental questions
about security in France multiple
attackers hitting a number of a target
using weapons from third party countries
and many of them were foreign nationals
we have a woman prepared to run at
police and blow herself up with a
suicide vest and their own number of
suspects still on the run nobody knows
where they
many are now beginning to question where
Schengen as the policy of open borders
is really sustainable thousands of
people continue to visit the various
locations of the Friday attack the
public is divided though on whether
stricter controls on movement should be
put in place not in the liberty of evil
to circulate its are free right to be
able to circulate and live our lives as
we wish and even the most powerful of
secret services will never be able to
stop people moving around I'm astonished
and I find it hard to understand how
this man could get through like this and
on reflection how ease even continued to
move around there all the evidence
suggests that more attacks are being
planned a terror network stretching from
Iraq and Syria across Europe this level
of danger and this type of organization
has never been seen before
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Paris